plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
[Musique]
pas de lien avec les derniers mots de
cédric joue via gabriel atallah vole au
secours de gérald darmanin le ministre
de l'intérieur critiqué sur la toile
pour ses propos hier sur des violences
policières
le mot j'étouffe du locataire de la
place beauvau a entraîné des réactions
en cascade les réseaux sociaux
la livraison aujourd'hui des cinq
premiers avions de combat français
rafale à l'inde les commandes qui
intervient alors que new delhi
entretient des relations tendues avec la
chine le pakistan
au total trente six avions doivent être
livrés par dassault
[Musique]
vers une accalmie dans l'un des conflits
qui secouent le yémen
les séparatistes du sud renoncent à leur
projet d'autonomie et se disent prêts à
mettre en oeuvre l'accord de ryad qui
prévoit un partage du pouvoir
un pays marqué par plusieurs guerres
imbriquer les unes aux autres
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous
très heureux de vous retrouver sur rt
france pour une nouvelle demi heure
d'information dernier conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui avant les vacances
à l'occasion pour gabriel attal de
revenir sur les propos polémiques de
gérald darmanin hier le ministre de
l'intérieur qui dit et tout fait en
entendant parler de violences policières
selon le porte parole du gouvernement
pas de lien avec les derniers mots de
cédric joue via décédé en janvier après
une interpellation controversée
évidemment ce terme n'a pas été employé
en faisant référence à la situation de
fait ce qui est arrivé à monsieur chouf
ya évidemment la question ne portait pas
sur ce point là et ça n'est évidemment
pas lié à cette à cette situation et
c'est important de le dire et vous avez
raison de poser la question puisque j'ai
vu que des questions ont été posées
notamment par la famille mais je tiens à
être clair sur ce point la maladresse ou
lapsus révélateur gérald darmanin à sous
le feu des critiques pour ses récents
propos sur les violences policières
un exercice de communication qui a
provoqué des réactions en chaîne sur les
réseaux sociaux
précision en images
quand j'entends le mot violence
policière moi moi je perds seulement je
m'étouffe
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais quelle honte monsieur darmanin vous
vous étouffer nous attendons vos excuses
et surtout une réponse positive à notre
demande de suspension en attente de
procès vous venez monsieur d'harmonie de
dépasser toutes les limites de la
décence vous mettiez indifférent plus
maintenant
à bientôt sous d'autres auspices
[Musique]
sur le cas précis du brigadier-chef ben
mohamed celui ci a effectivement dénoncé
alors pardon de le dire mais c'est
exactement ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui à ma
connaissance avec retard c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'il vit un peu reproché
[Musique]
l'igpn a relevé des comportements tout à
fait appropriée de la part de six
fonctionnaires de police elle a proposé
bien avant la révélation par article de
presse d'hier à renvoi devant le conseil
de discipline avec 4 sanctions directes
et une alternative aux poursuites
disciplinaires et dans les quatre
centres en direct il ya aussi monsieur
benoit ben mohamed
nous soutenons a marre brigadier-chef
qui pour avoir dénoncé racisme et
maltraitance par des policiers et mis
sous pression par un ministre continuons
à montrer notre soutien
le ministre de l'intérieur reproche à
monsieur benmohamed d'avoir dénoncé
tardivement ses collègues malgré les
rapports adressé à sa hiérarchie
ils dénoncent également des mesures de
rétorsion à son égard sous couvert de
procédures igpn
[Musique]
et en direct dans ce gîte et philippe
pascot auteur du livre mensonge d'état
aux éditions max milo
bonsoir philippe pascot merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
je cite évidemment ce terme je m'étouffe
à n'a pas été employé en faisant
référence à ce qui est arrivé à monsieur
chevaux via ce sont les mots cet
après-midi de gabriel attal comment
est-ce qu'il faut interpréter la réponse
du porte parole du gouvernement après
les propos controversés de gérald
darmanin bain juste interpréter que
maintenant on a un gouvernement de
branquignols
on a des gens qui se couvrent les uns
les autres comme ces gens là depuis
quelques temps passent leur temps à se
couvrir de leur connerie plutôt qu'à
faire fonctionner l'état j'étouffe
maladresse ou provocation mais non
lapsus révélateur ces mêmes c'est même
pas une provocation
ces gens là entre eux rigole du bas
peuple
vous vous rendez compte qu'aujourd'hui
au monsieur
un ministre se permet d'incriminer un
lanceur d' alerte en lisant mai mais
monsieur vous vous en mettez du temps à
dénoncer en appuyant bien sûr le mot
dénoncé alors que monsieur darmana va
porter plainte contre amer parce qu'il a
employé un certain mot au moment où
justement il y avait beaucoup de
dénonciation séjour la marche sur la
tête et darmanin on avait on avait déjà
un ministre de l'intérieur celui d'avant
qui était une autre tâche complète et là
maintenant on a un branquignol la
famille de cédric se souvient réclame
des excuses est-ce qu'elle aura gain de
cause selon vous et si oui quel sera le
message envoyé par gérald darmanin qui
essaient de renouer les liens avec
au ministère les liens entre son
ministère et des forces de l'ordre après
la confiance rompue sous l'ère
christophe castaner que vous venez
d'évoquer soit dans vos propos à vous et
vous rêvez chers amis es ce que vous
avez entendu une seule fois
ces gens là s'est excusé de la façon
dont ils ont géré la crise sanitaire du
coc vide les erreurs qu'ils ont fait les
manipulations qu'ils ont fait les
anciens qu'on a laissé mourir dans les
ehpad est ce que vous en avez entendu un
s'excuser est ce que vous avez entendu
castaner s'est excusé sur le matraquage
dijoud dans la rue ces gens là ne vont
pas à s'excuser
ils vont faire des circonvolutions c'est
parce que je voulais dire mais je les
dis quand même c'était le dernier
conseil des ministres avant les vacances
qu'elle analysait ce que vous faites de
cette dernière phase de communication du
gouvernement
ah non c'était pas moi je parle plus de
conseil des ministres je parle de cirque
vous rendez compte qu'on a aujourd'hui
un gouvernement qui n'a jamais été aussi
nombreux alors qu'en fin de compte le
président de la république annoncé en
début de mandat qu'il allait resserrer
les liens
il n'y a jamais eu autant de
collaborateurs de ministres c'est la
soupe qui sont tous en train de manger
avant de partir en s'enfuyant
est ce que cette séquence peut déboucher
sur l'embout sur des manifestations
après les récentes contestations
justement pour dénoncer les violences
policières avec les lois qu'ils ont
passés avec le masque avec
l'interdiction de manifester à plus de
10 avec les chaleurs qui arrivent mais
pour eux c'est un bonheur les
manifestations telles pour les entend
aujourd'hui on pourrait pas lieu moi
j'en vois pas la première grosse
manifestation ça va être le 12 septembre
merci à philippe pasqua d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes écrivain et auteur du livre
mensonge d'état aux éditions max milo
avec avec un dess et en parlant de
manifestation le comité des droits de
l'homme de l'onu réaffirme aujourd'hui
le droit à manifester pacifiquement
l'instance met en garde contre les
prétextes sécuritaires ou sanitaires
pour entraver ce droit fondamental
ces deux organes indépendants est
composé de 18 experts chargés
de vérifier la bonne application du
pacte international sur les droits
civils et politiques
il publie des instructions sur le
concept de rassemblement pacifique et
sur les devoirs des gouvernements sur
fond de pandémie mais on en parle dans
cette édition avec benoît martin
secrétaire général de la cgt paris on
conçoit revenant martins merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france comment est-ce que vous
accueillez ces instructions publiées par
le comité des droits de l'homme de l'onu
écoutez moi je porte un avis tout à fait
positif c'est extrêmement intéressant
cet avis juridique de ring de l'onu
l'osce et une réaffirmation du droit
international par le fait de dire et de
redire que le droit de réunion pacifique
constitue le fondement même d'une
société démocratique
c'est tout à fait le bienvenu dans cette
période de troubles et à de crise là ni
terre de crise démocratique un peu
partout dans le monde et on a bien vu
par exemple avec le mouvement black la
russe matters que ça s'est étendu comme
une traînée de poudre un peu partout
dans le monde il ya eu des mobilisations
est compris dans des des endroits où ce
n'était pas vraiment autorisé de se
réunir mais ça ça c'est quand même fou
et et donc les manifestants général ou
conscience de la nécessité d'appliquer
des gestes d'arrière avant qu'il faut
concilier le droit de se réunir de
manifester avec les précautions
sanitaires
est ce que ces instructions à ce
qu'elles ont un côté contraignant est ce
qu'elles vont être entendus appliquées
par les états ou bien est ce que ce ne
sont finalement que des recommandations
c'est un avis juridique un qui
pourraient être mobilisées en cas de
saisine d'une juridiction papa doc si
demain la la cgt saisir les juridictions
compétentes par rapport à droit de
manifester qui aurait été restreints et
bien le juge pourra et nous dans notre
dans notre plaidoirie en souriant
mobiliser cet avis juridiques de l'onu
et une sangle du ont sans nul doute ça
pourrait compter par contre il n'y a pas
de combats d'hier de l'application
automatique le gouvernement par exemple
français va tenir va prendre acte a
effectivement de 2,7 et véridique mais
il ne va pas forcément le mettre en
oeuvre
automatiquement le comité souligne
également le droit des journalistes et
des observateurs des associations de
défense des droits de l'homme à couvrir
à documenter les rassemblements y
compris ceux qui sont interdits et
violent cette crise sanitaire mondiale
est ce qu elle soulève finalement un
problème de liberté de la presse à
travers le monde ah oui et également on
a bien vu ces derniers temps aux états
unis mais par exemple également le site
et hong kong mais on peut citer paris
aussi bien voilà donc
ces dernières années notamment depuis
deux ans et que vous vendez déjà les
journaux on a bien vu que parfois dans
des journalistes en se voyait entravé
dans l'exercice de leur mission
d'information du matériel a été cassé
des journalistes ont été parfois
molestés ou pris dans des événements qui
les dépassait totalement un aigu à des
violences policières
et c'est tellement de reparler de ces
violences policières en ce moment
beaucoup de gens site max médard ou cv
sociologues parlent de la daf il la
violence légitime le monopole de la
violence légitime qu'exerce l'état mais
il faut pas faire dire non plus à webber
ce qu'il n'a pas dit à ce qui est
légitime les pèlerins légitime défense
des policiers dans certaines
circonstances mais les forces de l'ordre
ne doivent pas faire tout et n'importe
quoi voilà on est dans un état de droit
donc vous comme moi comme monsieur macro
comme un policier - jordan ou ne peuvent
pas être violent alors ce qu'ils voient
la skins c'est une règle générale de
droit commun rendu policiers et les
gendarmes peuvent l'être dans certains
cas peuvent faire usage de la force mais
faut que ce soit justifié
en vertu de circonstances particulières
et donc ces derniers temps ça a été
difficile comme l'a stipulé à gérald
darmanin hier ben oui monsieur darmana
oui oui d'ailleurs il n'est pas du tout
bien venu lui au ministère de
l'intérieur son comportement par rapport
à des femmes notamment
voilà je voulais dire que effectivement
vous aura présente sur la séance un le
concernant oui mais ça c'est comme
lorsqu'un trop cette année en
effectivement des magistrats appliquent
ce principe extrêmement important de
l'autre raison de son innocence mais
nous séduire la société lorsqu'on reçoit
dans nos permanences des femmes et qui
ont subi des violences on les croit pour
revenir sur le sujet de l'onu le comité
des droits de l'homme de l'onu je cite
les motifs généraux comme l'ordre public
ou la sécurité publique ne constituent
pas des bases solides pour interdire des
rassemblements pacifiques mais si le
nombre de contamination augmente
sensiblement après une manifestation à
ce qu'il y'a pas un problème à ce moment
là est ce que le droit de manifester est
plus fort que l'enjeu de santé publique
l'enjeu de santé publique peut être
relevé par une pleine transparence dans
la formation et puis une pleine
démocratie
donc voila vous savons un tout les
projets du gouvernement un qui veut
continuer à réformer des réformes
néolibérales donc ils sont prêts à tout
pour restreindre les crédits relais les
résistances 1 qui pourraient se former
et y compris utiliser la question
sanitaire comme prétexte pour pour
restreindre des droits de manifester
donc moi je peux vous dire que demain à
paris aura une manifestation de jeunes
migrants un mineur qui sont totalement
livré amène donc il ya un certain nombre
d'organisations dans la cgt on va les
soutenir
d'autres manifestations ont eu lieu y
compris des lunes et des manifestation
contre les violences policières à
caractère raciste et donc ce soit à fait
malvenu 1,2 de réprimer
mouvement social dans son ensemble merci
benoît martin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la cgt paris le
risque d'une deuxième vague de
coronavirus plus que jamais d'actualité
alors qu'un regain épidémique semble se
confirmer
quatorze nouveaux foyers de
contamination et 14 décès recensés ces
dernières 24 heures trente de cas
supplémentaires à quiberon selon la
préfecture du morbihan 72 personnes sont
désormais affectés dans la ville
bretonne qui ferme ses plages la nuit
pour limiter la circulation déco vide
19 malgré ses récents chiffres pas
encore de deuxième réaction le ministre
de la santé
olivier ferrand en déplacement tout à
l'heure dans les yvelines pour
superviser la distribution de 50
millions de masques aux foyers les plus
modestes 1 on n'est pas dans une
deuxième vague du coronavirus on est
dans la poursuite de l'épidémie
il y à des signaux d'alert provenant de
certains hôpitaux avec une tendance du
nombre d'admissions et du nombre
d'appels est l'une des solutions face au
concours en à virus un vaccin
plusieurs laboratoires se sont lancés
dans la course pour trouver un précieux
cerrone le français sanofi et le
britannique qui à dsk viennent de
conclure un accord avec le gouvernement
britannique pour fournir 60 millions de
doses
les phases de tests débuteront en
septembre
sanofi et james qui assure que ce vaccin
pourrait être prêt pour le premier
semestre à 2021
c'est le quatrième contrat de ce type
signé par le royaume uni mais gérard des
lipides chirurgien et statisticien
dénonce un choix précipité de la part
des états je ne suis pas contre les
vaccins mais encore faut-il que le
vaccin soit une barre sur un tir sans
danger et d'autre part efficace et pour
cela comme tout traitement quel qu'il
soit en médecine il faut qu'on puisse
juger de ses avantages et de ses risques
éventuels
or se précipiter pour acheter un vaccin
qui n'existe toujours fort me paraît
complètement fou est ce que vous achetez
vous une voiture qui n'existent pas
semblant ça me paraît incroyable
donc là les gouvernements agissent par
peur qu'ils ont fait d'ailleurs pour
imposer le shutdown en angleterre
le confinement en france confirmera
venir s'en séparer les gens malades des
gens sains ce qui a aggravé les réelles
et la mortalité d'épidémie donc je
dirais wait and see
attendons et voyons les résultats
objectifs de ces taxes avant de
l'acheter un vaccin d'un côté traitement
de l'autre la commission européenne
passe une importante commande de trente
mille antiviral haram désirent un
contrat d'une valeur de 63 millions
d'euros selon le ministre de la santé
olivier verrons ce médicament aurait
pourtant une efficacité extrêmement
relative on écoute la porte-parole de la
commission européenne
[Musique]
hier la commission a signé un contrat
avec la société pharmaceutique gilead
pour la sécurisation des doses de
traitement de vcli la marque de raismes
d y virent à partir de début août des
lots de ce médicament avec le riz seront
mis à la disposition des états membres
et du royaume uni
dès qu'ils disent oui la proximité cela
garantira le traitement d'environ trente
mille patients présentant des symptômes
sévères du coït 19
ce premier lot ne répondra donc qu'aux
besoins immédiats
dans le même temps la commission prépare
également un marché commun pour de
nouvelles fournitures de ce médicament
qui couvrira des besoins supplémentaires
à partir d'octobre et la vice-première
ministre russe évoque elle de son côté
la production de deux vaccins pour des
tests en septembre et en octobre
le courant n'a virus qui menacent de
malnutrition 7 millions d'enfants
supplémentaires dans le monde selon
l'unicef plus de précisions en images
[Musique]
m
les etats unis annoncent leur
positionnement de onze mille 900
militaires en europe jusqu'ici passée en
allemagne les troupes vont partir pour
la belgique et l'italie
washington envisage également d'envoyer
des forces en pologne et dans les états
baltes si un accord est trouvé avec ces
pays
une manoeuvre visant à accentuer la
pression sur les pays de l'otan qui ne
contribuerait pas suffisamment au budget
de l'alliance atlantique selon la maison
blanche
livraison aujourd'hui des cinq premiers
avions de combat français rafale à
l'inde une commande à date ans dès 2016
qui intervient dans le cadre d'un accord
controversé de plusieurs milliards de
dollars et dans un contexte de tension
entre new delhi et pékin
françois xavier lambert côte à côte les
cinq rafale escorté par deux avions
russes fendent le ciel en direction de
l'inde après un voyage de plusieurs
heures ils ont atterri sur la base
militaire damballa dans l'état indien du
haryana ces cinq rafale sont les
premiers à être livrées sur les 36
commandé par l'inde à dassault montant
estimé du contrat 9,4 milliards de
dollars le ministre de la défense indien
a profité de l'occasion pour lancer un
avertissement à peine voilé à la chine
alors que les deux pays entretiennent
des relations tendues
je voudrais ajouter que si quelqu'un
doit s'inquiéter de ces nouvelles
capacités de l'armée de l'air indienne
où les critiques et ce devrait être ceux
qui veulent menacer notre intégrité
territoriale
le 15 juin dernier en incidence en blanc
a éclaté entre militaires indiens et
chinois dans le ladakh une région
disputée entre les deux pays
une vingtaine de soldats indiens perry
c'est lors de cette confrontation qui a
conduit un renforcement de la présence
militaire indienne dans la zone
après quelques jours de tension la chine
et l'inde avaient cependant annoncé
poursuivre les discussions afin
d'apaiser la situation
du côté chinois qui nous ne voulons
assurément plus voire d'heures avec les
indiens
c'est dans ce contexte de discorde avec
la chine mais aussi avec le pakistan que
l'inde renouvelle sa flotte
vieillissante d'avions de combat mais ce
contrat passé avec dassault a déclenché
des protestations de l'opposition
indienne
celle ci a notamment accusé le
gouvernement donne à rennes drame audi
d'avoir favorisé le conglomérat privé
ryan ce groupe comme partenaire de
dassault aux dépens de l'entreprise
publique h à elle la polémique n'a
pourtant pas remise en cause le contrat
avec l'avionneur français qui espère
profiter de ces dissensions pour vendre
davantage de rafale à new delhi la
commande actuel doit être totalement
livrés d'ici fin 2021 conflit imbriqués
les uns aux autres yémen mais l'un
d'entre eux pourrait se diriger vers une
accalmie et séparatistes du sud
renoncent à leur projet d'autonomie et
se disent prêts à mettre en oeuvre
l'accord de ryad qui prévoit un partage
du pouvoir
le pays est toujours plongé dans une
crise humanitaire qui est la pire au
monde selon les nations unies
clément hospital c'est une guerre dans
la guerre qui divise un pays déjà bien
fragilisé par des conflits
communautaires et les interventions
étrangères
alors qu'ils sont en principe alliés
contre les rebelles houthi le
gouvernement yéménite et les
séparatistes du conseil de transition du
sud
le stc se disputent le contrôle du sud
du yémen
l'accord de ryad a signé en novembre
2019 prévoyait pourtant un partage du
pouvoir dans cette partie du territoire
mais ces dispositions n'ont quasiment
jamais été en vigueur jusqu'à ce que les
saoudiens propose un plan pour accélérer
sa mise en oeuvre
il prévoit notamment la nomination d'un
nouveau gouvernement d'ici à 30 jours
ainsi que celle d'un nouveau
gouvernement à aden la capitale du sud
du pays où sont basés les séparatistes
de quoi satisfaire le porte parole du
stc
le conseil de transition annonce
l'abandon de la déclaration d'auto
gouvernance afin de permettre à
l'alliance arabes de mettre en oeuvre
l'accord de ryad
nous affirmons la poursuite et
l'approfondissement de notre partenariat
stratégique avec l'alliance arabe à tous
les niveaux politique militaire
économique et sécuritaire à travers nos
objectifs communs de lutte contre l'
ingérence iranienne dans la région
contre les groupes terroristes et contre
les activités des extrémistes ce
consensus trouvé entre ryad et les
séparatistes du stc
redonne de l'espoir aux acteurs des
négociations selon le vice ministre
saoudien de la défense
grâce aux efforts du prince héritier il
a été possible de réunir le gouvernement
yéménite et le conseil de transition du
sud pour qu'ils s'accordent sur le
mécanisme proposé par l'arabie saoudite
afin de mettre en oeuvre l'accord de
ryad et d'instaurer la paix la sécurité
et une prospérité durable au yémen en
parallèle d'autres négociations sont en
cours depuis quatre mois entre le
gouvernement et les rebelles houthi
l'envoyé spécial de l'onu pour le yémen
déplore que les discussions soient
longues et difficiles et affirme que le
pays traverse les pires moments de son
histoire
le yémen est en effet dévasté par la
guerre brutale que mène la coalition
saoudienne contre les outils depuis 2015
une guerre qui non seulement détruit le
pays mais qui a également tué au moins
100 mille civils et rendu les deux tiers
de la population soit 24 millions de
personnes dépendant d'une assistance
humanitaire toujours plus rares céline
je réside spécialistes deviennent même
des plans une géopolitique complexe dans
la région voyez son analyse
on a plusieurs gares ou yaman ya pas que
les outils et à l'ailé les groupes
extrêmes al qaïda m mais il ya aussi
d'autres groupes que les gens
connaissent pas vraiment et aussi les
tribal tout est imbriqué
les choses sont imbriquées les unes dans
les autres et il est très compliqué la
géopolitique du reste les jeux
politiques qui est compliquée et
complexe
aujourd'hui le stc à a senti et il sait
très bien que les outils vont pas
s'arrêter à la frontière d'abyane ont à
la frontière des tiles ils vont
commencer à avancer sûrement mais
doucement mais sûrement vers le sud
alors je parle laden j'ai partagé par
agrément je parle de chabwa je parle de
toutes les régions
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont décidé de se
rallier à nouveau au gouvernement
yéménite
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
votre attention prochains mois sur la
formation dans une demi heure vingt
on se donne rendez vous donc dans 30
minutes à tout alors restés sur des
france
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france